you know that frustrating feeling when a
message takes more than a few seconds to
send well it's hard to imagine today but
before the mid 19th century sending news
across the ocean could take weeks to
arrive then thanks to an incredible yet
mostly forgotten technological
achievement that gap was shrunk from
weeks to seconds a feat that kicked off
the global age of instant communication
that we take for granted today for most
of human history the only way to send a
message across a long distance was to
have it delivered in person which was
limited by how fast someone could travel
the invention of the electric telegraph
in the 1830s sparked a revolution
it allowed messages to be sent across
wires as electrical pulses which could
be translated into letters and words
within a decade of its invention
thousands of miles of telegraph cables
were installed between major cities
worldwide linking governments businesses
individuals and the press but there was
still an enormous daunting gap how to
send a signal thousands of miles across
the vast Atlantic Ocean linking Europe
in the Americas in 1854 an ambitious
wealthy young American entrepreneur
named Cyrus Westfield was presented with
a business opportunity to connect a
telegraph cable from New York City to
Newfoundland which would shorten the
arrival of news by ship from abroad by a
day or two he'll push the idea even
further what if the line can be extended
all the way to Ireland and then on to
London which at the time was the hub of
the global economy sensing that his
project could change the course of
history field was undaunted by the
immense challenge he raised money from a
wide network of investors including the
British and American governments which
also provided the necessary ships for
laying the cable in exchange for top
priority communication rights on the
future telegraph line field also
recruited some of the top engineers and
scientists of his time to develop a
cabled durable enough to carry a signal
thousands of miles across the ocean
floor
laying out the actual cable by steamer
ship in the rough waters of the North
Atlantic was no easy feat either and in
fact the first two attempts failed when
the cable snapped and sunk on a journey
wasting investor money dashing hopes and
causing widespread public mockery of the
project some of the criticisms were
philosophical and eerily relevant today
Wood instant access to information
really make us any happier or better off
nevertheless in August 1858 after over a
year of disappointments the two massive
cable Lane ships successfully reached
their destinations in Newfoundland and
Ireland completing the connection that
field and others have prophesied once
the line had been tested an official
message of goodwill was exchanged
between Queen Victoria and US President
James Buchanan public celebrations
erupted in cities throughout the US and
Europe marking the dawn of a new era of
unification between the old world and
the new it's hard to overstate how
influential the so-called electric union
was to the rapidly globalizing world of
the 19th century it meant that
everything from stock and commodity
prices to a declaration of war or peace
could now be shared immediately it's no
surprise that fields accomplishment was
widely heralded at the time as the
greatest human achievement in history
and filled himself became an
international hero although the first
cable only function for a few months
before going dead it proved that a link
was indeed possible within a decade more
reliable and sophisticated undersea
cables were laid by field and many
others throughout the 20th century cable
networks expanded and technology
continued to evolve as telephones
eventually replaced Telegraph's and then
digital data eventually replaced analog
signals while the original transatlantic
cable could only transmit a few words
per minute at best
today's fiber optic cables deliver
hundreds of terabytes of data in just
seconds and there are a lot of them
stretching close to 750 thousand miles
in total and more cable was laid in 2018
than in any year in almost two decades
instead of brave entrepreneurs now most
new cables are being laid by the tech
giants such as Amazon Facebook Google
and Microsoft which collectively owned
or lease more than half of the undersea
bandwidth and although it seems that we
live in a mostly wireless world undersea
cables still carry 99% of data traffic
that crosses the oceans so the next time
you chat with someone on the other side
of the world keep in mind that it all
started over 150 years ago by a
visionary entrepreneur and his team
pulling off what was once called the
greatest work that the genius of man
ever contemplated
[Music]
you